¿Qué es la bioenergía? La bioenergía no es etanol.
La bioenergía no es calentamiento global. La bionergía
es algo que parece contraintuitivo. La bionergía es
petróleo. Es gas. Es carbón. Y parte de construir
ese puente al futuro, a un punto en el que efectivamente
podamos ver los océanos de manera racional,
o poner estas órbitas geo-espaciales que darán vueltas o
harán microondas u otras cosas, va a depender de cómo
entendamos y manejemos la bioenergía. Y para hacer
eso, realmente deben mirar primero a la agricultura.
Entonces hemos estado plantando cosas por once mil años.
Y a medida que plantamos cosas, lo que aprendemos
de la agricultura es que debes lidiar con pestes,
debes lidiar con todo tipo de cosas asquerosas,
tienes que cultivar cosas.
En la medida que aprendes cómo usar agua para cultivar, vas
a poder ser capaz de emigrar fuera del Nilo.
Vas a ser capaz de inyectarle energía a cosas, entonces
la irrigación genera una diferencia.
La irrigación te permite empezar a plantar
cosas donde tú quieras, en vez de sólo donde crecen
los ríos. Comienzas a obtener esta agricultura
orgánica, empiezas a meterle maquinaria a todo esto.
La maquinaria, agregándole un montón de agua,
lleva a una agricultura a gran escala.
Juntas las máquinas con agua, y obtienes
paisajes de este tipo. Y entonces obtienes
ventas que se ven así. Es fuerza bruta.
Entonces lo que has estado haciendo con la agricultura es empezar
con algo que representa un sistema razonablemente
natural. Comienzas a domesticar ese sistema natural.
Le agregas mucha fuerza al sistema natural.
Le pones un montón de pesticidas y herbicidas --
"¿Piensa que SU trabajo involucra un montón de excremento?" (Risas) -- a ese sistema natural, y
terminas con un sistema que se ve así.
Y es todo fuerza bruta. Y esa es la manera en la que
nos hemos enfocado en la energía. Entonces la lección
en agricultura es que efectivamente puedes cambiar el
sistema basado en fuerza bruta, al comenzar a
unir el sistema, aprendiendo del sistema y efectivamente
aplicándole biología. Y se cambia de una
disciplina de ingeniería, se cambia de una
disciplina de química, a una disciplina de biología.
Y probablemente uno de los seres humanos
más importantes del planeta es este tipo detrás mío.
Este es un tipo llamado Norman Borlaug.
Ganó el Premio Nóbel, tiene la Medalla de Honor del Congreso,
se merece todas estas cosas.
Y se las merece porque probablemente ha alimentado
a más personas que cualquier otro ser humano vivo,
porque investigó como agregarle biología a las semillas.
Él hizo esto en México. La razón por la cual India
y China ya no tienen hambrunas masivas es porque
Norman Borlaug les enseñó a cultivar los
granos de manera más eficiente e impulsó la Revolución Verde.
Eso es algo que mucha gente ha criticado.
Pero, por supuesto,
esa gente no se da cuenta que China e India, en vez
de tener grandes cantidades de personas muriendo
de hambre, están exportando granos.
Y la ironía de este sistema específico es que
el lugar donde realizó su investigación, que fue México,
no adoptó esta tecnología, ignoró esta tecnología,
habló de por qué se debería pensar en esta tecnología
pero no aplicarla en realidad.
Y México sigue siendo uno de los mayores importadores
de grano en el planeta porque no aplica
una tecnología descubierta en México.
Y, de hecho, no ha reconocido a este hombre, al punto
que no hay estatuas de este hombre por todo México.
Sí las hay en China e India.
Y el instituto que este tipo dirigía ahora se ha cambiado a India.
Esa es la diferencia entre adoptar tecnologías
y discutir acerca de tecnologías.
Ahora, no es sólo que este tipo alimentó grandes cantidades
de personas en el mundo. Es que este es el efecto
neto en términos de lo que la tecnología hace,
si comprendes su biología asociada.
¿Qué pasó en la agricultura?
Bueno, si tomas la agricultura a través de un siglo,
la agricultura en 1900 habría sido reconocible para
alguien que plantaba hace mil años atrás. Sí, los arados
se ven distintos. Las máquinas son tractores o cosas
en vez de mulas, pero el campesino habría
comprendido, esto es lo que está haciendo este tipo,
lo está haciendo por esta razón, hacia acá es hacia donde va.
Lo que realmente comenzó a cambiar para la agricultura fue cuando
empezó a transformarse de esta ingeniería y química
de fuerza bruta a la biología. Y ahí es donde
consigues tus incrementos en productividad.
Y mientras haces esas cosas, esto es lo que le pasa a la
productividad.
Básicamente, pasas desde tomar 250 horas para producir 100
almudes, a cuarenta, a quince, a cinco.
La productividad laboral para la agricultura aumentó siete veces, entre 1950 y 2000,
mientras que para el resto de la economía aumentó 2,5 veces.
Esto es un aumento absolutamente masivo
en la cantidad producida por persona.
El efecto de esto, por supuesto, no son sólo olas
ámbar de granos, sino montañas de esta cosa.
Y el 50 por ciento del presupuesto de la UE va a
subsidios de agricultura para las montañas de cosas
que la gente ha sobreproducido.
Esto sería un buen resultado para la energía. Y por
supuesto, en este punto, probablemente estás diciéndote
a ti mismo: "Mismo, yo pensé que venía a una charla
sobre energía, y aquí está este tipo que habla sobre biología".
Entonces, ¿cómo se relacionan estas dos cosas?
Una de las ironías de todo este sistema es que
estamos discutiendo qué hacer con un sistema que
no entendemos. Ni siquiera sabemos qué es el petróleo.
Ni siquiera sabemos de dónde viene.
Quiero decir que, literalmente, todavía es objeto de debate
qué es este río negro de cosas y de dónde viene.
La mejor suposición, y una de las mejores hipótesis,
es que esta cosa sale de estas otras cosas.
Estos absorben la luz solar,
se pudren bajo presión por millones
de años, y obtienes estos ríos negros.
Ahora, lo interesante de esa tesis -- si
termina siendo cierta -- es que el petróleo,
y todos los hidrocarburos, terminan siendo
luz solar concentrada. Y si piensas en
bionergía, la bioenergía no es etanol. La bionergía
es tomar la energía solar, concentrarla en amebas,
concentrarla en plantas, y quizás es por eso que obtienes
estos arco iris.
Y mientras estás mirando este sistema,
si los hidrocarburos son luz solar concentrada,
entonces la bionergía funciona de otra manera. Y tenemos
que empezar a pensar en petróleo y otros hidrocarburos
como parte de estos paneles solares.
Quizás esa es una de las razones por las cuales
si vuelas sobre el oeste de Texas, el tipo de pozos que
comienzas a ver no son tan distintos a las fotos
de Kansas y las parcelas irrigadas.
Así es como cultivas petróleo. Y mientras piensas sobre
cultivar petróleo y cómo ha evolucionado el petróleo,
comenzamos con este enfoque de fuerza bruta. ¿Y entonces qué
hemos aprendido? Aprendimos que tenemos que hacerlo más grande.
¿Y después qué aprendimos? Que después tenemos que
llevarlo aún a mayor escala. Y nos estamos poniendo realmente
destructivos al salir y cultivar esta bioenergía.
Estas son las arenas de brea de Athabasca, y hay una
enorme cantidad -- primero de minería, los camiones
más grandes del mundo funcionan acá, y entonces
tienes que extraer este lodo negro viscoso,
que es básicamente petróleo que no fluye. Está unido a la arena.
Y después tienes que usar mucho vapor para separarlo,
lo que sólo funciona a los precios
de petróleo actuales.
Carbón. El carbón resulta ser virtualmente la misma
cosa. Es probablemente plantas, excepto que estas han
sido quemadas y comprimidas bajo presión.
Así que tomas algo como esto, lo quemas, lo
pones bajo presión y, probablemente, obtienes
esto. Aunque, nuevamente, repito: no lo sabemos.
Lo cual es curioso mientras debatimos todo esto.
Pero mientras piensas en carbón, así se ven los
núcleos de trigo quemados. No tan distintos al carbón.
Y, por supuesto, las minas de carbón son lugares muy peligrosos,
ya que en algunas de estas minas obtienes gas.
Cuando ese gas explota, la gente se muere.
Entonces estás produciendo un biogás de carbón en
algunas minas, pero no en otras.
En cualquier lugar en donde encuentres un diferencial,
se generan preguntas interesantes. Preguntas sobre
que deberías estar haciendo con esta cosa.
Pero de nuevo, carbón. Quizás la misma cosa, quizás el
mismo sistema, quizás bioenergía, y estás aplicándole
exactamente la misma tecnología.
Aquí está tu enfoque de fuerza bruta. Cuando lo logras
a través de fuerza bruta, entonces sólo
remueves cumbres de montañas completas. Y terminas
con la fuente más grande de emisiones de carbono,
que son las plantas generadoras a carbón.
Ese probablemente no es el mejor uso de la bionergía.
Mientras piensas en cuáles son las mejores alternativas a
este sistema -- es importante encontrar alternativas,
porque resulta que Estados Unidos está disminuyendo
sus reservas petrolíferas, pero no disminuye sus
reservas de carbón, y tampoco lo hace China.
Hay tremendas reservas de carbón existentes allá afuera, y
tenemos que comenzar a pensar en ellas como energía
biológica, porque si seguimos tratándolas como
energía química, o energía ingenieril, vamos a
estar en caquita bien honda.
El gas es un tema similar. El gas también es un producto
biológico. Y mientras piensas en gas, bueno, estás
familiarizado con el gas. Y esta es una manera distinta de
obtener carbón.
Esto se llama metano en lecho de carbón.
¿Por qué es interesante esta foto? Porque si el carbón resulta ser
vida vegetal concentrada, la razón de que puedas
obtener un diferencial de gas producido entre una mina
y otra -- la razón de por qué una mina puede estallar
y otra puede no estallar -- puede ser porque hay
cosas comiéndose este carbón y produciendo gas.
Este es un fenómeno muy conocido. (Risas)
Comes ciertas cosas, y produces mucho gas.
Puede resultar que los procesos biológicos en las minas
de carbón sigan el mismo proceso. Si eso es verdad,
entonces una de las maneras de extraer la energía
del carbón puede no ser volar las cumbres enteras de
montañas, así como puede no ser quemar el carbón. Puede sí ser
tener cosas que procesen ese carbón de forma biológica
como se hizo en la agricultura.
Eso es la bionergía. No es Etanol.
No son subsidios a unas pocas compañías. No es la
importación de maíz a Iowa porque has construido
demasiadas plantas de etanol. Es comenzar a
comprender la transición que ocurrió en la
agricultura, de fuerza bruta a fuerza biológica.
Y en la medida que puedes hacer eso, puedes
limpiar algunas cosas, y limpiarlas
bastante rápido.
Ya tenemos algunos indicadores de productividad
para esto. Ok, si le insertas vapor a campos de carbón
o campos de petróleo que llevan funcionando
décadas, puedes obtener un aumento realmente
substancial, como de ocho veces,
en lo obtenido. Esto es sólo la etapa inicial de lo
que puedes hacer.
Y mientras piensas en biomateriales, este tipo -- que
hizo parte del secuenciamiento del genoma humano,
que acaba de doblar la base de datos de genes
y proteínas conocidas en la tierra navegando alrededor
del mundo -- ha estado pensando acerca de cómo estructurar esto.
Y hay una serie de personas
inteligentes pensando en esto. Y han estado creando
empresas como Synthetic Genomics, como
aCambria, como Codon, y lo que estas empresas están
tratando de resolver es, ¿cómo aplicas principios
biológicos para evitar la aplicación de fuerza bruta?
Piénsalo de la siguiente manera. Piénsalo como
comenzar a programar cosas para propósitos específicos.
Piensa en la célula como un hardware. Piensa en
los genes como un software. Y en la medida en que
comienzas a pensar en la vida como código
intercambiable, que puede convertirse en energía, que puede
convertirse en comida, que puede convertirse en fibra, que puede
convertirse en seres humanos, que puede convertirse en
toda una serie de cosas. Entonces debes cambiar
tu enfoque respecto a cómo vas a estructurar y
tratar y pensar acerca de la energía de un modo
muy distinto.
¿Cuáles son los principios iniciales de esto
y hacia dónde nos dirigimos? Este es uno de los
gigantes gentiles del planeta. Es uno de los seres
humanos más simpáticos que conocerás. Su nombre es
Hamilton Smith. Ganó el Nóbel por descubrir cómo
cortar genes -- algo llamado enzimas de restricción.
Estaba en Hopkins cuando hizo esto, y es un tipo
tan modesto que el día que ganó, su madre
lo llamó y le dijo: "No sabía que había otro
Ham Smith en Hopkins. ¿Supiste que acaba de
ganar el Nóbel?" (Risas) Esa fue su mamá, para que vean.
Bueno, de todos modos. El tipo tiene clase. Lo
encuentras en su puesto todos los días, trabajando
en una pipeta y construyendo cosas. Y una de las cosas
que este tipo recién construyó son estos.
¿Que es esto? Es el primer transplante de
ADN desnudo, donde tomas el sistema operativo ADN
completo de una célula, lo insertas en una célula
diferente, y haces que la célula comience a
funcionar como una especie distinta. Esto es de hace un mes. Verás cosas
durante el próximo mes que serán igual de importantes
a esto.
Y mientras piensas en esto y en las consecuencias
de esto, vamos a comenzar no sólo a convertir
etanol desde maíz con altos subsidios.
Vamos a comenzar a pensar acerca de
biología ingresando a energía. Procesar estas
cosas es muy caro, tanto económicamente como
energéticamente.
Esto es lo que se acumula en las arenas de brea de
Alberta. Son bloques de azufre. Porque a medida que
separas el petróleo de la arena, y usas una cantidad
enorme de energía en generar vapor -- para separar
estas cosas -- también debes extraer el
azufre. La diferencia entre crudo liviano y
crudo pesado -- bueno, es como 14 dólares
el barril. Por eso estás construyendo estas
pirámides de bloques de azufre. Y por cierto,
la escala de estas cosas es muy grande.
Ahora, si puedes retirar parte del componente
energético utilizado, reduces el sistema, y
realmente comienzas a aplicar principios biológicos
a la energía. Esto tiene que ser un puente al punto en que
se pueda llegar a generar energía de viento, en que
se pueda llegar a solar, al punto en que se pueda llegar
a nuclear -- y ojalá no construyas la próxima
planta nuclear en una hermosa costa marina al lado
de una falla sísmica. (Risas) Es sólo una idea.
Pero mientras tanto, al menos por la próxima década,
el nombre del juego es hidrocarburos. Y sea eso
petróleo, sea eso gas, sea eso carbón, esto es lo que nos
concierne. Y antes que alargue esta charla demasiado,
esto es lo que está sucediendo en nuestro sistema actual
de energía.
86 por ciento de la energía que consumimos son
hidrocarburos. Eso significa que el 86 por ciento de lo que
estamos consumiendo son probablemente plantas procesadas
y amebas y todo el resto de esto. Y hay un rol en
esto para la conservación. Hay un rol en esto para
las soluciones alternativas, pero también debemos
solucionar esta otra porción.
Cómo lidiamos con esa otra porción es nuestro
puente al futuro. Y mientras pensamos en este puente
al futuro, una de las cosas a considerar es que hoy
estamos dejando alrededor de dos tercios del petróleo
dentro de esos pozos. Entonces estamos gastando una
cantidad enorme de dinero y dejando la mayor parte de
la energía allá abajo. Lo que, por supuesto, requiere de más
energía para extraer la energía. Las proporciones se
vuelven idiotas para cuando consideras el etanol.
La razón entre energía ingresada y energía obtenida
puede incluso ser uno a uno. Es una manera
estúpida de manejar el sistema.
Último punto, último gráfico. Una de las cosas que debemos
hacer es estabilizar los precios del petróleo. Esto
es como se ven los precios, ¿de acuerdo?
Este es un sistema muy malo dado que lo que sucede
es que la tasa de retorno se ubica muy abajo. A las personas
se les ocurren ideas brillantes para paneles solares, o para
viento, o para alguna otra cosa, ¿y luego
adivina qué? El precio del petróleo se va al suelo.
Esa empresa quiebra, y entonces puedes volver a subir
los precios de nuevo.
Así que si pudiera hacer una modesta sugerencia para
cerrar, fijemos un precio estable para el petróleo
en Europa y Estados Unidos. ¿Cómo logras esto? Bueno, fijemos
un impuesto al petróleo no asociado al ingreso,
que básicamente diga que por los próximos 20 años,
el precio será -- lo que quieras, 35 dólares, 40
dólares. Si el precio de la OPEP cae bajo esto,
se cobra el impuesto. Si el precio de la OPEP sube
sobre esto, se retira el impuesto.
¿Qué logra esto para los emprendedores?
¿Qué logra para las empresas? Le dice a la gente,
si puedes producir energía por menos de 35 dólares
el barril, o menos de 40 dólares el barril, o menos
de 50 -- debatamos este tema -- tendrás un buen
negocio. Pero no forcemos a la gente a pasar
por ciclos donde la investigación no paga, ya
que tu empresa va a la quiebra mientras la OPEP
restringe las alternativas y frena el desarrollo de la
bioenergía. Gracias.